The country that has one government
another stable government
algé
good moro is goodiaco
of Tony
Mauritania
How do you think I mean Palestine
not me I don't give
even my opinion is not really valid not
expert but tell you mention the ransom and
firstly the mention
that was free they could even free the
houses
and hiing
I'm going
me wee
better before
you know many they don't know what jihad
is what they know is the jihad of
Marxism and socialism and the  jihad of
the Cuban what name that Cuban guy
revolution
his name I don't know hgh
ins
was
Okay.  Imagine now I don't give you the
whole food but you fight against me
you're not taking food and slimming
taking the food from you and slinging you
know I'm saying is look
if they were winning why the people
protesting against and who the war they
were not in the waring
the count we have our
muslim